who takes down the strongest upper moons
and who takes down our favorite all of
that will be discussed in this video as
we break down who killed every hashira
and Demon moon in Demon Slayer so make
sure to stay tuned for that smash that
like button if you enjoy seeing these
demonstrate videos on the channel and
want to keep them coming make this the
video you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
demonstrate videos and updates and now
without further Ado let's jump into its
spoilers and all let's get the ball
rolling with lower Moon 5 rui despite
tanjo and nezuko's best efforts rui was
about to finish them off but then water
hashragyu shows up this is one of the
biggest Flexes in the series as rui
launches his best attacks gyu's facial
expressions don't even change he uses
his own created form Dead Calm to
completely nullify to his attacks then
before rui can even try another attack
gyu cuts his head off in the blink of an
eye again without changing Expressions
it's almost as if GUI is Bored killing
this demon that Tandra nesuko had so
much trouble with and that is how the
water hashra killed lower Moon 5 rui
after rui dies an angry schools on
summons all the lower moons frustrated
with how weak they are he decides that
lower moons are of no use to him and
kills lower Moon 6 kamanui followed by
lower Moon 4 mukago followed by lower
Moon 3 wakuraba and lastly lower moon to
rokuro he decides he likes lower Moon
one and mu and gives him an abundance of
his blood to make him stronger so in one
Fell Swoop muzon wiped out almost all of
the lower Moons for us next predictably
comes lower Moon 1 and Moo's death this
death was less straightforward as enmu
joined bodies with a train flame hashira
rengoku zanitsu and nazuko worked on
protecting the people on the train while
inosuke and tanjo went for the kill
while inosuke's attack exposed enmu's
neck train tanjiro is the one who
delivered the finishing blow to it using
hinokami kagura Clear Blue Sky however
it was definitely a team effort and
while then Goku and them kept and moved
from absorbing people and getting
stronger inosuke helped tanjiro and even
saved him when enmu got tanju to almost
take his life for real because he
thought he was still in an enmu induced
dream now before we move on to the first
hashira death we'll be discussing let's
wrap up with the lower moons including
the ones from Bonus materials first
let's mention a lower Moon I easily
forget about because he's not a lower
Moon by the time we meet him in the
series I'm referring to lower Moon 6
kilgai the drum demon he used to be
lower Moon 6 before Muson stripped him
of that title for not being strong
enough Tundra is the one who kills him
by using water breathing 9th form
splashing water flow turbulent now if
you're wondering for this attack I'm
using the official Shonen Jump
translation tanjiro uses the ninth form
because it minimizes Landing time and
landing area making it perfect for kill
guy's rotating room tendra tells kyogai
that his blood demon art is incredible
before he cuts off his head leading the
dying demon to ironically shed tears of
joy in his final moments he finally felt
like someone admired him after a
lifetime of rejection now we get to the
still Cannon but bonus material lower
Moon demons former lower Moon to Hyrule
was featured in kyojiro and Goku's Side
Story and not surprisingly kill Jordan
Goku was the one to finally end him
using the strongest flame breathing form
9th form Ren Goku AKA Purgatory in his
human form that demon was a swordsman
who got made fun of for sticking to an
outdated weapon like a sword by men who
used guns so as a demon he fights with
guns now thinking they're better
automatically however since his guns
don't beat rengoku he finally takes the
shape of a Giant Shadow Wolf and tries
using a sword against rengoku it's not
enough but as Hydro is evaporating he
says that he admires on Goku's
swordsmanship a part of him is no doubt
glad that rengoku proved that swords are
still a viable weapon in the modern age
at least in the Demon Slayer world and
with heidel's death then Goku earned his
promotion to hashira so we saw the lower
Moon then Goku had the kill to become a
hashira but next we have the lower Moon
sanami had to kill to become the wind
hashira I'm talking about lower Moon one
ubume her blood demon art was illusion
manifestation sonomi was able to escape
from her Illusions because his friend
and fellow went style user broke her
demon dispelling mirror which weakened
the power of her Illusions sanami was
able to end her and become a hasha as a
result but not before she used her
illusion powers to kill sami's friend
masachika next let's turn to kojo
rengoku who met his aunt in the most
epic fashion possible against upper Moon
3 akasa then Goku's goal was to protect
everyone else present and not only did
he succeed in doing that he genuinely
scared akasa and made the upper Moon
think his own end might be near even
though it and Goku didn't even awaken a
Demon Slayer Mark then Goku was on the
offensive when akaza got a lethal attack
on it and Goku and penetrated his guts
with his arm then Goku used this to flex
and trap Arkansas's arm inside as Dawn
was approaching then Goku summoned what
akasa described as unbelievable power he
used one arm to start cutting akaza's
neck and the other to hold akasa's free
arm a freaked out akaza had no choice
but to tear off his arms and run for his
life as he's dying then Goku's miles and
has time to give tanjiro important
information in a pep talk he tells him
no matter how weak or unworthy you feel
keep your heart burning grit your teeth
and move forward if you just curl up in
a ball and hide time will pass you by it
won't stop for you while you wallow in
grief don't worry over my death I'm a
hashira it's my job to Shield you junior
members he tells our three demons saying
Amigos that someday they will become
hashra and be the pillars of the
demonstrator core that's what he
believes he tells them again that he
believes in them and dies with a big
smile on his face as his mother's Spirit
tells him he did splendidly it's in
Goku's death and how he handled it that
makes him one of my favorite characters
in the entire demonstrator series next
up let's look at how upper Moon 6
gyutaro and dakim at their end of course
since both of their necks have to be cut
at the same time this had to be a team
effort Tundra does splendidly against
kyotaro with a sickle stuck in his jaw
Tundra keeps swinging he decides he
needs to summon a hundred times his
usual strength strength and the scar on
his forehead spreads to look more like
yorichis as his eyes turn completely
white similarly to howren Goku turned
aka's attack against him kyotaro
comments that Tundra is not letting him
pull his sickle out of Tundra's jaw in
this awakened demon Mark form tanjura
succeeds in mustering the strength
necessary to cut off kyotaro's head
while zanitouni nosuke together Succeed
In cutting daki's tricky sash-like neck
by slashing their swords in opposite
directions even as guitara andaki are
dying yutor releases one last attack but
luckily our guys all survive as they are
evaporating at first qutarandaki are
upset with each other Tundra after
beating yutaro steps in and tells them
that as brother and sister they
shouldn't talk like that and should
stick together until the end and they do
eventually take his advice as they make
up and enter the Flames of the other
world together now of course sound hasha
tangent helped during this fight too as
did his wives at times and even nezuko
but it was tanjiro who landed the
finishing blow and who must get the
credit for killing gutaro while
zaituninosuke get the credit for taking
down Doki next up we have upper Moon 5
gyoko who met his end at the 14 year old
missed hashida's hands this was a
significant feat because ahasha managed
to solo an upper moon for the first
known time after activating his
demonstrate Mark power up muichiro was
significantly stronger and faster than
gyoko Yoko even unveiled his final form
which was supposed to be tougher than
diamonds and which allowed him to turn
everything he touched into fish like a
fishy Midas Touch however he couldn't
land any hits on a Demon Slayer Mark
muichiro even if the latter was poisoned
muichiro ends up being so fast that he
cuts gyoko before the latter even
realizes what happened he even thinks to
himself what's happening why is
everything upside down not realizing
it's because muichiro had already cut
off his head the narrator explains that
muichiro used the seventh form of
misbreathing to defeat Yoko a technique
that uses wildly fluctuating speed to
confuse one's opponent when you show
yourself you move as slow as a turtle
but when you're hidden you move in the
blink of an eye its top speed is even
faster than gyoko even the narrator has
to admit that this was indeed an
incredible turn of events that an
already injured muichiro defeated an
upper Moon and as gilko is evaporating
he still won't shut up questioning how
he could lose to a mere human and how
everyone is an ungrateful maggot and so
on and so on finally muichiro can't take
anymore and cuts up the already
evaporating head saying that's enough
just go to hell already it really Hypes
up muichiro who did so well against
upper Moon 5 after tengen Tundra and
everyone else struggled so much against
weaker upper moons gutero and daki next
we gotta turn to Upper moon for
hantangu's death which was yet another
team effort but tanju gets the kill in
the end notably awakened Mark mitsuri's
role was even more difficult because she
had to occupy zohaku 10 Han tengu's
strongest form all on her own for an
extended period of time so that tanjiro
and the others could deal with the main
body's head it's ironic like she
arguably did more to contribute to Upper
Moon Forest defeat but the fight ends
with her about to be beaten by zohakuten
and thus not looking that impressive
while Tundra gets the Epic moment of
glimpsing into the transparent world to
see that the real body is in the heart
and then in Epic fashion he slices the
tiny but strong neck with his bright red
blade at first he thought they won but
lost nezuko because nazuko kicked him
away from her so he wouldn't choose to
protect her from the Sun instead of
going after the demon who was targeting
people however she finally gains
immunity to the Sun and thus its wins
all around and a lot of people were
saying that these demons this season
were weaker than utero which isn't true
but I get why some people think that and
why it feels that way because demon
Sarah Mark mitsuri could hold off sohaku
then so well because Demon Slayer Mark
muichiro completely outclassed Kyoko and
because Tundra finished off a constantly
running away Han Tengu it just didn't
feel quite as satisfying as the upper
Moon 6 fight where they just barely
pulled off the win akaza's death is an
interesting one
fought him together and Tundra is the
one who temporarily outclassed him when
he reached the selfless state or what
akasa calls the domain of Supremacy that
he himself has been seeking all this
time Tundra even warned him the attack
was incoming and akasa couldn't react in
time and got his head cut off so it
sounds like Tundra killed akaza right
but that's not the end of the battle
akasa keeps fighting with a headless
body he begins to change into something
different into a demon-like muzon that
can't die through decapitation it's made
clear that tanjo and gyu are out of
energy tendro even drops his sword from
exhaustion so it looks like akazah who's
regrowing his head is about to win but
then with a smile on his face he's
self-destructs a part of it is because
he feels like he lost the moment tanjo
cut off his head but the more important
reason is that he regained his memories
and the spirit of his love koyuki made
it possible for him to fight against
muzon's influence through her he was
finally able to let go and evaporate so
although you could say that tanju
outclassed them and made him suffer a
symbolic defeat akasa is the one that
took his own demon Life Next we have
another hashira Rumble hashra jigoro say
to Sensei AKA Gramps like akasa gigoro
took his own life when he found out that
zenitu Senpai and his other student
kaigaku chose to become a demon jiguro
took it as his own failure and
responsibility that one of his students
became a demon so he committed seppuku
zaitsu found out through a letter and
was especially upset because jigoro
didn't have a second to help with the
ritual and thus suffered much more than
necessary zaitsu got more serious than
ever before as he decided that he had to
avenge his Graham's death by beating
kaigaku and now that's a perfect
transition to kagaku's death kaigaku
most likely because there were spots
open became the new upper Moon six
Saints who fought this thunder-breathing
demon Moon alone and he ends up killing
him in Epic fashion using his own
created Thunder breathing form not to
mention the strongest under breathing
form seventh form honoi kazuchi nokami
AKA flaming Thunder God yes that is is
indeed an epic name not only is it cool
that it has the word God in the title it
also takes the form of an epic looking
giant electric dragon kagaku didn't see
it coming in fact he even says I didn't
see that he says it was so fast which
keep in mind is High Praise from a demon
enhanced Thunder breather Thunder breath
style users are known for their speed
after all at first kaigaku takes solace
in the fact that at least it looks like
zaitu is falling to his death as well
however yoshiro saves him while also
rubbing it in the decapitated kaigaku's
face saying it's a Pity to die alone
kagaku is left alone to evaporate while
zenitu's wounds are treated promptly and
so kagaku's death coincides with
zayasu's revenge and his most epic
moment in my opinion next is nakime's
death who replaces huntengu and takes
the upper moon for a possession but it
feels like an empty title since she had
no title when the roles were filled and
she is not strong offensively nakime
ends up being defeated and tricked by
the combined efforts of iguro mitsuri
and yoshiro who takes an control of her
mind and makes it seem to her and moves
on like she defeated iguro and mitsuri
if you know Naruto it's like a genjutsu
illusion when muza finds out what's
happening he uses his power to kill her
but fortunately yoshiro is able to get
them all out of the infinity Castle
before her cells completely die so not
an especially strong upper moon or a
particularly climactic death but notably
it was accompanied with yushiro's most
epic moment now on to Upper Moon 2
doma's death one of my favorites and
this one is definitely a team effort we
can't discuss Thomas death without
mentioning
flowerhoshalakana's death and later
insectashi rashinobu's death let's start
with the backstory of kana's death one
day she ran into upper moon to Doma she
was fatally wounded in this encounter
but the sun was coming up and dolma
didn't succeed in absorbing her as he
likes to do with women he had to run
away shinobu got there before her older
sister Kane died Kane wants her sister
to live a normal life but chinobu
insists on being told what demon did
this to her she wants revenge seeing how
committed shinobu is Kanye finally
decide guides to describe Doma to her
before she dies she reveals everything
she knows about dolma which shinobu will
use to come up with and execute her
master Revenge plan now back to her main
story and the moments surrounding doma's
defeat Doma was way out of Kano and
inosuke's League his ice clones alone
were a handful for them so you can bet
they would have had no chance in a
normal fight against full power Doma
however as he's about to leave them in
the hands of his Heist clones his face
starts to fall apart it's revealed that
this is the result of shinobu's poison
and master plan I personally love
well-executed impatient Revengers in
fiction and this is one of those for
over a year shinobu continually took in
wisteria flower poison she was
determined to kill the demon that killed
her older sister flowerhashirakana
although she knew from the beginning
that her sword couldn't deliver a lethal
amount of poison to Doma she made sure
her body would deliver 700 times a
normal lethal Mount and yes 700 is the
official number while the mangaka
accidentally put 70 in the weekly
children magazine so from the beginning
her plan was to make it look like she's
trying to win but to get absorbed by
dolma and that's exactly how it went
down it takes a while for all that
poison to take effect but it does and
this is when kanal takes her chance she
uses one of the coolest breathing
techniques flower breathing final form
Vermilion eye it stains the eyeballs red
because of the pressure it puts on them
it can lead to blindness but in exchange
the user raises Dynamic Vision to the
utmost and makes surrounding movements
look dull and slow this technique allows
her to get close enough to doma's
rotting neck she starts to cut it but
his ice powers freeze her before she can
finish then inosuke uses one of my other
favorite techniques Beast breathing
sudden throwing strike which is pretty
much him just throwing his swords like
ninja stars the swords reach and push
Canal's sword enough so that it makes it
through dolma's rotting neck perhaps he
was strong enough to regrow his head
like akaza if it wasn't for the poison
but as things stood Doma simply
evaporated so this battle was definitely
a team effort that involves shinobu
kanau and inosuke and maybe even Kanye
for giving important information to
shinobu but I'd personally give the most
credit to shinobu for this death upper
Moon once that was another massive team
effort notably it involved three of the
strongest hashira stonehasha gome when
hasha sanami Mr
as well as Kenya and what I find most
impressive about this Victory is that
everyone played such a vital and
complementary roles in taking upper Moon
one kokushibu's head the big shift
happened thanks to the strongest hashra
gilme he gained acts through transparent
World a top tier power-up and since
kokoshibo also had access to it gomi
could use that knowledge to trick
okushibu he was able to catch him off
guard with a rosary it hit kokoshibo's
hand and that led to an attack from
sanami then the spiked ball taking off
his arm and then we should have stabbed
him because the rosary changed the
trajectory of kokoshibo's attack just
enough for muichiro to just barely Dodge
and get this vital stab in kokushibu
even says that yomei deceived His Eyes
by using the knowledge of the
transparent world to control his own
blood circulation and in this way he
messed up kokushiwo's attack then even
not hashiragenya plays a a role firing
his upper Moon enhanced blood demon art
bullets at kokoshibo although kokushibu
tries to deflect the bullets like living
things turned and sank into kokoshibo's
body then the bullet Sprout into tree
roots that should help to immobilize
kokoshibo and suck okushable's blood the
source of his blood demon art kokushibu
panics and is able to launch countless
Crescent blades from his body they cut
the roots katmuichiro and ganya while
sanami and gome avoid the attacks then
muichiro only has the top half of his
body remaining is such a boss that he
not only holds on to a sword but turns
his sword bright red the strongest and
most effective color against demons as
kokoshibo points out it creates intense
pain like his insides are on fire sonami
attacks while genya still has plush
bullets in the upper Moon's body more
tree roots Sprout out and kokoshiva
realizes he can't use a technique
presumably because the roots are sucking
his remaining blood the source of his
techniques then gilme drops his spike
ball on kokushibu's head and it's still
not enough nevertheless kokoshima points
out that he can't use a technique
because the tree in his back is sucking
up his blood his body seizing up due to
the intense pain of muichiro's red
Katana he's dealing with all of this
with Gomes spike ball pushing down on
him and finally the final piece comes in
with sun and me who hits down on the
spike ball with his own sword both
weapons turn red and the added pressure
is enough to finally take off
kokoshibo's head so getting to this
point was definitely a team effort Gomez
started the Domino effects with a mere
Rosary but everyone played a vital role
however as with akaza decapitation
doesn't spell the end for this demon
kokushibu becomes more monstrous than
ever as he regrows his head gomi and
sanami keep pressing him kokushibu even
says that he overcame decapitation and
now any kind of attack other than
sunlight is meaningless just as he's
thinking no one can beat him now he sees
his reflection inside of his sword the
monster staring back at him shocks him
he says it's so ugly he always wanted to
be the strongest Samurai but now he
questions himself is this really how A
Samurai looks he asks himself if this is
really what he wanted and at this point
only when he psychologically begins
falling apart his body follows starting
where muichiro his descendant stabbed
him so yes all four of these demon
Slayers helped take down kokoshibo but
like with akaza it seems that kokoshibo
played a role in his own death like
akaza psychologically he no longer had
an unpolluted will to fight on and so
his own psychology it seems clear is
what ultimately contributes to the death
of this demon who as he himself said
reached a point where nothing but the
sun which wasn't present in the infinity
Castle could defeat him but that's not
to take away from sanami gomeichiro in
genya it was because they did so well
and pushed him to this point that he
became so obviously monstrous even to
himself and had to face this
psychological breakdown in other words
their efforts led to his death even if
his death was ultimately the direct
result of his internal struggle and just
to externalize his internal struggle
further we find out at the end that Koko
she will never let go of his humanity
and past as symbolized by the fact that
he kept the flute that his brother
gifted him on his person after all these
centuries if he had completely abandoned
his Humanity chances are he would have
gone on living and killed even sodomy
and Gomez not just muichiro and genya so
now it makes sense to look at missed
Hashem muchiro's death and as with
hashira shinobu's death and khana's
death muichiro's death was covered while
discussing the demon that killed them
obviously kokoshibo does end up killing
muichiro he couldn't survive being cut
in half after kokushibu evaporates we
see that muichiro 2 has now passed on
kyomi says it's thanks to muichiro that
they won and that for one so young he
really was magnificent to the end
muichiro reunites with his twin
brother's spirit and although his
brother is upset at first that muichiro
died muichiro says he doesn't regret
risking his life for his comrades they
finally come to an understanding and
have a cathartic hug and cry together
next now that all the upper Moon deaths
have been covered we gotta discuss the
hashira death that happened as a result
of the muzon fight after giant baby
moves on evaporates we see gilmei the
strongest hashiro he fought to the end
and even after losing a leg continued to
pressure giant baby muzon but now he's
telling them not to waste medication on
him he knows that it's too late for him
he's selfless to the end and tells them
calmly to go see to the younger fighters
he says it's his last request then he's
reunited with the spirits of the
children he used to watch over before
they ended up getting killed by a demon
they apologized for that day the day of
the tragedy they explained that they
weren't trying to run away they wanted
to protect yomei because he was blind
one says he wanted to go outside for a
farming tool to use as a weapon and
another wanted to call for help yomey
too is sorry he couldn't protect them he
blamed himself for it for all this time
but the kids tell him not to apologize
they all hug him and tell him they love
him they say they have been waiting this
whole time for him yomi is relieved and
thanks them he says then let's go
together and die smiling and of course
with tears running down his eyes as
usual but this time they are tears of
Joy next up we see mitsri and iguradai
from the Fatal wounds that moves on
inflected on them as mitsuri is dying in
igoro's arms they confess their love to
each other mitsuri begs to be igoro's
bride if they're reborn as humans and he
says of course if she agrees to have him
this time he will make her happy and
protect her so she doesn't end up dead
and if you watch my all secret romances
in Demon Slayer video you know that they
do get their happy ending and their
reincarnations run a family restaurant
together sonami almost dies but the
spirit of his father says he can't go
yet AKA he can't die yet and sends him
back to the world of the living he tells
him to be thankful he's his son and so
he's extra tough so by the end only
sanami and guiu of the current hashira
survive while out of the former hashira
tengen urakodaki and shinjiro survive
thus all these characters presumably get
to die of natural causes or just
straight up old age since Geo and send
me awaken demonstrator marks it's
possible if you want to get dark to
argue that they die by 25. since that's
what happens to most marked ones but
since the demons have been defeated I
think it's fair to assume that the
demonstrator curse has been lifted as
well either way we know that giyu sanami
and Tangen all live long enough to have
kids and shinjuro already has senjuro as
we know who will live on and have
descendants of his own so that is the
death of every hashira and Demon Moon
and who killed them but what's even
crazier is the countless secret romances
that take place in demons here before
all the death and sometimes after it so
if that sounds as interesting to you as
it does to me then you won't want to
miss my all secret romances in
demonstrator explained link on screen
right now and I'll see you there